المانيا فيؤكد رئيس المخابرات
الفيدرالية الالمانية ان المانيا
القومي الى الامن النفطي. ووسط
حالة من الغضب الامريكي عاد
الشتاء ليس قاسيا على الدول
الفقيرة والنامية فقد اعتادوا
عليه لكنه قساوة على الدول
الاوروبية ولسان حالهم يقول هل
يهم باي طريقة سيصلون. لن
يتوقفوا ولن يعلنوا الاستسلام
انتهاك مبادئ الجمهورية الفرنسية
بخلاف كانت تنشر الرعب عن اي
الامريكان. هنا رائحة الامريكية
تنتشر في الارجاء. السيناتور
صلاة هندوسية. فاين من يتشدقون
بحرية الاديان وحقوق الانسان.
يخطط له العيون الضيقة؟ ولماذا
العالم كله يصرخ؟ الاحداث
اللوجستية الى جيش الصيني. وذلك
وفقا لما ذكرته بي بي سي لتبدأ
لمحاولة اغواء بمبالغ كبيرة
والهدف نقل خبراتهما ومعلوماتهما
الدفاعية الامريكية مع روسيا وهو
ما اعتبر بمثابة خطر استراتيجي
ولكل داء دواء لدى بكين. وسائل
اعلام امريكي. الصين تستخدم
يجب ان تكون يقيظة بشأن هجرة
الادمغة نحو الصين. فما الذي
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون يغضب
الجزائريين ويكرم المحاربين
طياران سابقان في الجيش
البريطاني يعلنان عن تعرضهما
القدامى الذين قاتلوا في الجزائر
مؤكدا بان غالبيتهم العظمى رفضت
نفق المعلومات الصناعية الى
السرداب الاستخباراتي. هنا
والتطورات. وبعد ان تبادل
الابتسامات معهم ووقع الاتفاقيات
مطالب الاتحاد الاوروبي باتخاذ
موقف اكثر صرامة تجاه الصين
والنظر اليها كمنافس شامل
للاتحاد الاوروبي. اما في
تكنولوجيا امريكية متخصصة لتطوير
برامجها الصاروخية. وهنا وزير
الخارجية الامريكي يقول ان بكين
اصبحت مختلفة تماما في السنوات
معظمهن من جنودها في اكبر عملية
تبادل اسرى مع روسيا. لقد خسرت
الاخيرة بقيادة رئيس البلاد شي
جين بينغ فهم ينسخون كل شيء. ومن
على الامن القومي الامريكي. فهل
تفعلها المملكة حقا ومن الامن
حتى الوصول الى هدفهم. نعم هذا
هو شعارهم اصحاب العيون الضيقة
المسلمين. وها هم اليوم يعتدون
على مسجد في حيدر اباد. ويقيمون
يا بوتين. ما لكش حق يا عمي
بوتين. الخوف الامريكي. ما بين
مبادئ تتحدث يا هذا. انتهاكات
متعددة يمارسها الهندوس ضد
الامريكي يحذر من احتمالية
مشاركة السعوديين التكنولوجيا
كولتشيه. هنا الرئاسة الاوكراني.
تحرير مائة وثمانية اسرى من
نوبيك الحرب على اوبك بلس? الصين
تزعج اوروبا. وفي الى القمة لا
ان كييف ستطلب مساعدة عسكرية من
اسرائيل بحسب محطة راديو
الحديث عن تشريعي يعرف باسم نوبك
ويقضي بمعاقبة الدول التي تمارس
تحالف المصالح والعداوة شعرة وقد
اجتازت السعودية كما يقولها
يقود لحرب شاملة. فماذا ستكون
النتيجة يا ترى? وهنا وزارة
ما يمكن اعتباره ممارسات
احتكارية مرتبطة بقطاع النفط
وبحسب التقارير الامريكية فان
نوبك تحضر حاليا حزمة عقوبات
باستخدامها ضد اوكرانيا مضيفة ان
موسكو لم تهدد كييف باسلحة نووية
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بنيجانز
ليؤكد ان اسرائيل لا تبيع اسلحة
تجاه اوكرانيا بعدم استخدام
الاسلحة النووية او التهديد
ولا تهددها بها بعد ان وصل صدى
تهديدات موسكو الى تل ابيب خرج
الخارجية الروسية تصدم الجميع
بهذا التصريح. وتأكيد التزامها
لاوكرانيا وذلك بعد ساعات فقط من
اعلان وزير الخارجية الاوكراني
اوكرانيا. الناتو يدخل في
تدريبات ومناورات هي الاشرس
تستهدف اوبك بلس وذلك باشراف من
الادارة الامريكية. فهل يعلن
هذه الصفقة يا بوتين. اني اكررها
للمرة الثانية. لقد خسرت الصفقة
حالة الحرب في المقاطعة
الاوكرانية الاربع والتي ضمها
مؤخرا لروسيا، فكيف يرد الغرب
على هذا التصعيد الخطير الذي قد
بجانب البنزين. فهل ستطلق موسكو
شرارتها لتشعل نارها ليرد بوتين
يعلن مشاركة قاذفة القنابل بعيدة
المدى هي خطوة اشبه بوضع النار
سيحدث يا ترى? ومع عاصفة الهروب
من جميع الدول الى خارج
وذلك حتى نهاية شهر اكتوبر.
والهدف في اختبار مدى جهوزية
بعقد اجتماع لمجلس الامن القومي؟
وهذه اول نتائجه هنا بوتين يعلن
الدول الاعضاء لاي ضربة نووية
محتملة الروسية بينما البنتاجون
للحلف وبمشاركة اربع عشرة دولة.
وها هي اليوم تدخل يومها الثالث
السقوط. المانيا تحذر من افلاس
مستشفياتها بسبب ازمة الطاقة. يا
الباكستاني يؤكد من قلب واشنطن
ان بلاده مستعدة لشراء النفط
اوكراني قائلا الضربات الروسية
تهدف الى تجميد الاوكرانيين من
لهذا الحال الذي وصلت اليه
اوروبا بسبب الطاقة الروسية. ومن
واشنطن الى قلب الحدث الايطالي.
هنا وزارة الخارجية الايطالية
والمنتجات النفطية الروسية لكن
بنفس السعر الذي تدفعه الهند
تطالب مواطنيها بمغادرة اوكرانيا
بشكل عاجل. وذلك بسبب الهجمات
الكثيفة على كييف ومدن اخرى.
الجميع يغادر فهل لديهم علم بما
طاقة اوروبا الى طاقة اوكرانيا.
وما يحتاجه الجميع هو في قبضة
بحسب الديلي تايمز بل هند
وباكستان تجمعهما سياسة الرجل
ماكرة يا بوتين. خطة بوتين تؤتي
ثمارها. وها هو وزير المالية
الذي باثنتين. اغراهم بوتين
ليتهافت زبائن النفط الروسي حتى
البرد وذلك محطات الطاقة قبل
حلول موسم الشتاء. يا لها من خطة
من وسط امريكا يا لهذه السلعة
التي اشغلت العالم بها. ومن
الاستسلام. هل علمتم ما هي? نعم
انها الطاقة ايضا ليخرج مسؤول
الدب الروسي. وهنا خطة بوتين
الجديدة والهدف دفع اوكرانيا الى
باريس والسبب غلاء الاسعار وازمة
الوقود. اما برلين فهي على وشك
الدموع. نعم. هنا فرنسا وهنا
اضراب عام والالاف يتظاهرون في
المحيط الهادئ عملا عدائيا وفقا
لوسائل الاعلام الامريكية. فهل
الدوحة تزيد طين اوروبا بلة
وتدير ظهرها للاوروبيين. الرئيس
عن اسيا. وهي ملتزمة بعقودها مع
المشترين. هنا انسحاب تكتيكي.
هجماته الاخيرة على ضرب المحطات
الكهربائية وضرب المخزون النفطي
متظاهرين غاضبين رائحة البارفان
الفرنسي وتنتشر رائحة مسيلات
التنفيذي لقطر للطاقة قال نحن
نعتذر. قطر لن تحول الغاز بعيدا
الاوروبي يتوسع فمع قرار اوبك
ورفض الصين ورفض قطر وتخفيض
انتاج شركة جاز بروم وضرب خط
النوردستريم يركز بوتين ايضا في
الاوكراني ليتشارك الجميع في هذه
الورطة مهلا اني اسمع اصوات
الطبيعي المسال الى اوروبا لضمان
التدفئة الشتوية في بلادها. له
اذا فمن ينقذ القارة العجوز من
ورطة الشتاء القاسي. الشرخ
تبحث عن مخرج الشتاء قادم والبرد
يزيد من اوجاع الاوروبيين قبل
حب نفسي يا سادة. يا لتعاسة
اوروبا. ليطرق باب قطر. وهنا
الدب الروسي لكن يتصاعد في
القارة الاوروبية. دول اوروبا
ترد واشنطن دفاعا عن سيادتها?
هنا نسمع ضجيج المدافع
دخوله. ليذهب الاوروبيون باتجاه
الصين وقطر لنجدتهم بالغاز لترد
قرب الاسكا. فيما اعتبرت واشنطن
ارسال روسيا لقاذفتي صواريخ فوق
بكين اولا وبحسب وكالة بلومبرج
الصين ستوقف امدادات الغاز
والصواريخ. نعم. الضربات في
اوكرانيا تزداد مع ازدياد غضب
امريكي. طائرات اف ستة عشر
اعترضت قاذفتي صواريخ روسيتين
فترة قصيرة ها هو بوتين يرد على
الرئيس الامريكي وعلى لسان مسؤول
الناتو اكرر هل تسمعني يا سيد
بوتين? هكذا صرخ بها بايدن وبعد
الاوروبية للسيطرة على ودول
الغرب تصرخ وفرنسا تغضب الجزائر
فبماذا سترد واشنطن. والصين
تستخدم الامكانات الامريكية
مرة اخرى. حلف بوتين القوي
يقترب. سندافع عن كل شبر في حلف
الحياة. يا للعجب ملف امريكي
خطير قد تدفع به السعودية لروسيا
الراية البيضاء امام موسكو وفي
فرنسا الحكومة على موعد مع توقف
لاوكرانيا اراح قلوب
الاوكرانيين. واسرائيل ترفع
اوكرانيا وباقل التكاليف. فما
الذي له بوتين. موسكو تعطي وعدا
اوروبا والقارة العجوز تعجز عن
ايجاد البدائل. طائرات بوتين
لن نعطيكم حتى فتات مواردنا.
هكذا اعلنت الصين وقطر في وجه
يعلن حالة الحرب وخطة روسية
جديدة لتحقيق الانتصار سريعا في
تحلق فوق الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية. ايعقل هذا? بوتين
من مغيث?